there are so many hidden secrets and
strange happenings that go down in the
final scene of carry so stick around to
the end of this video if you want to see
me analyze it this video is sponsored by
privacy.com who are offering a few new
product options so keep watching to
learn more as a special treat for my
things you miss viewers you'll get five
dollars to spend on your first purchase
free money that you can use to purchase
anything online go to privacy.com to
sign up now
[Music]
i've covered the stephen king universe a
lot here on this channel but one thing
that i've yet to do is take it back to
the creation of this universe i'm not
talking about gon
the almighty being in king's writing i'm
talking about when king himself actually
created the universe by writing his
first novel carrie which was published
in 1974.
the first movie adaptation would come
out two years later so let's get into
the things you missed
the movie begins in carrie's gym class
where we learn that she's basically an
outcast among her classmates she showers
alone in the locker room after all the
other girls have cleared but in the
background there's a poster advertising
the senior prom to take place on may
25th and later become the climactic
scene of this movie the poster is light
blue with text printed on cloud designs
and it would be the rain-like downpour
of water sprayed by kerry using her
telekinesis that sparked the electrical
equipment and started the tragic fire at
the prom the poster's color scheme
light blue and white comes up again and
again to symbolize an innocent purity
for example carrie goes into the prom
without having ill intentions and the
place is decorated with a light blue
color scheme but the kids who are trying
to sabotage her are wearing red
which is explained by carrie's mother to
be the color of the devil
red i might have known it would be red
and when carrie is humiliated she
changes all of the lights in the room to
red
other examples of the good vs evil color
scheme can be seen throughout
miss collins is dressed in light blue
when she saves carrie from the bullying
girls carrie wore a light blue dress
while walking home after being
victimized warlight blew to school the
next week as she rejoins classes and
compliments tommy ross on his poem
tommy picks her up in a light blue car
before prom an event that was sue
snell's way of making up for the
bullying that occurred and carrie
changes into a blue gown after
attempting to wash away the evil symbol
of the blood after the prom
on the other hand red manifests itself
as evil like the red blood that marks
the beginning of kerry's womanhood and
the truck that approaches the house when
tommy asked her to the prom
both of which her mother sees as sinful
in the book the prom dress is red but in
the film it's pink but mrs white still
labels it as
the color of the devil obviously there's
the blood that gets dumped on carrie at
the prom but there's also the red car
that billy nolan uses to try to run her
over
at the end the quilt at sue's house at
the end is a mix of reds and light blues
which like the novel's ending suggests
that
nothing has really been solved aside
from the symbolism of colors there's
also a good deal of symbolism for
adulthood
remember carrie's entire manic
telekinesis episode is powered by the
stress of her getting her period
reaching adulthood going on dates which
alone is fine but the stress is
multiplied by the humiliation caused by
her classmates so i think it's no
mistake that the shower scene that kicks
it all off features a very
adult-oriented nozzle head and is filmed
in an almost
sensual way also it's right after carrie
literally drops the soap that she
becomes extremely vulnerable
if you don't know what i mean just
google and drop the so the gym teacher
that helps her is miss collins her name
is changed from mrs jardin in the novel
apparently just because that's easier to
pronounce
this is also the first film role for
betty buckley who i'm a big fan of for
her work and split and the happening
when carrie gets ready for the dance we
see a newspaper clipping by her mirror
celebrating tommy ross for winning the
player of the year award it's implied
that he plays multiple sports but this
seems like the most generic thing ever i
mean it could refer to the fact that he
essentially has two dates in the movie
his girlfriend sue
and his prom date carry then there's
this strange scene carrie's mother who
is sworn off sex is a sin
is seen in mutilating this carrot which
could be seen as another phallic symbol
there are a couple more adult symbols at
the prom
outside of this part where i'm not
really sure why this much older english
teacher is looking at the young first
year gym teacher like that but i'll
ignore that and focus on
the curious change from the book in the
novel carrie starts destroying the gym
by causing the emergency sprinklers to
go off but in the film it's a much more
masculine image in that she uses the
ability to spray the fire hose to ignite
the chaos there's one motif that
manifests itself
time and time again over the course of
carrie's run time the religious symbols
that are craftily sewn into many of the
scenes
let's start with the devil references
this time the movie that tommy and sue
watch when he agrees to ask harry to the
prom
is a 1966 film called a duel at diablo
the house that carrie lives in with her
mother is designed to look like a church
mrs white male orders her own crucifix
after deciding that the baptist church
in town participated in the ways of the
devil but the movie takes it a step
further with its arcing doorways and
massive leonardo da vinci painting when
carrie returns home after her rampage
she returns to the sound of church music
and the smell of burning flames from the
candles that her mother is placed all
over the house including on the bed
i too like to live dangerously that's
why
i live in california
[Music]
the house represents a sanctuary for mrs
white but just outside of its walls is
where evil lurks as seen by the parking
spot indicator that resembles an
inverted cross
mrs white meets her fate when she ends
up being crucified after trying to take
down her daughter who she believes to be
an agent of the devil there is more in
that final scene but i'll tackle that
all together when i come back with more
things you missed
making purchases online has become the
new normal it's so easy but a lot of the
time i forget to think about the
merchants and their data partners who
can see our personal information
whenever we make a purchase i've been
using privacy.com to protect me they
make it super easy to protect your
financial life online by generating
virtual card numbers that hide your real
bank information they also let you set
limits on each virtual card to protect
you from unwanted charges going through
what they give you
for free is awesome you can create up to
12 virtual cards per month they've also
just introduced two new plans the pro
plan
is ten dollars a month and gives you
everything from the free plan plus one
percent cash back on all purchases 36
cards per month and even more security
and privacy features
teams and small businesses are obviously
going to be better off on the team plan
25 a month it gives you access to
everything from the pro version
plus dedicated account management 60
cards per month and
transaction limits tailored to your
business needs if you go to my link
privacy.com's world you get five dollars
for free if you're not gonna take five
free dollars what are you even doing
with your life privacy.com
slash cheesy's world
[Music]
when tommy and kerry walk into the prom
the band is playing a song whose lyrics
sing
the devil's got a hold of his soul the
song is called education blues by vancer
towers and if you flip the gender of the
subject of this tune it could easily be
interpreted to be about carrie white
let's roll it
[Music]
it's talking about a school-aged kid who
doesn't fit into societal norms and
subsequently goes on a rampage
[Music]
in carrie's case she has a reputation
around the school causing constant
bullying and graffiti reading carrier
white vernon
[Music]
obviously a reference to carrie's mom
believing that she's an agent of the
devil
also uncoincidental i'm sure is tommy
ross's reasoning behind voting for
themselves for prom king and queen
come on to the devil with false modesty
the prom itself is a very foreign thing
to carry and i don't think it would be
too much of a stretch to call an event
centered around social interaction to be
very alien for her
not you we'll cover you one day but the
prom scene is filmed as if it truly is
another planet from the theme love among
the stars to carry describing her
experience to mrs collins it's like
being on mars
to the shot of carrie and tommy dancing
where they spin on an axis as the camera
orbits around them
much like a solar system also we're not
going to ignore the fact that there are
clearly dragon balls on stage right
vegeta how many things you missed and
carry
it's over nine but before we look any
further into the prom scene let's
discuss
how it was set up when kerry is sitting
in english class there are a couple of
things to note the first of which is a
poster for hamlet the shakespearean
tragedy
known for spoiler alert even though it
came out 420 years ago
the fact that nearly everyone dies in
the end the shot with both carry and
tommy in frame utilizes something called
a split focus diopter
let me explain the foreground and
background are sharp and in focus
but the middle ground is not normally
this effect would be impossible to
achieve
because in cinematography you can only
have your focal length set to one
position at a time just as
under the normal circumstances of high
school culture tommy and kerry would
never go out on a date but director
brian de palma uses this device the
split focus diopter to set
different focal lengths for the left and
right side of the image just like how
under extraordinary circumstances
tommy and carrie are together you can
see it in some other diploma films but
it's honestly a bit dated today if we
wanted to achieve that we'd probably use
a green screen
not that i'd know anything about that
the name of the high school has been
changed from you in high school in the
book to bates high school in the film
i think this was an homage to the
classic horror film maybe the most
classic of all horror films
psycho which takes place at the bates
motel the music that accompanies
carrie's use of her powers
is very similar to the score from psycho
and of course both movies feature iconic
shower scenes
the mascot of bates high school is the
stingers a hornet-like creature
in film music terminology a stinger is a
short sound used for emphasis
emphasis much like the psycho-inspired
sound that i just mentioned
that might be why bates mascot is the
stingers the idea comes back during
carrie's meltdown at the prom where she
sees in kaleidoscope vision
something commonly associated with how a
hornet might see the world
in this scene carrie is essentially an
angry hornet whose classmates have just
shaken up her nest
there are a couple of easter eggs
referencing obscurities from the book
one of the nominees for prom queen is
cora wilson who we can assume is one of
the wilson sisters mentioned earlier by
the coach
watson and the wilsons the wilson
sisters are assumed to be adapted from
the tibeto sisters in the novel a pair
of twins who partake in the bullying of
carrie
in the movie cora is seen dancing with
this guy who may or may not be her date
frank greene but is definitely credited
as the beak now in the novel the beak is
a boy named freddy holt he's only
mentioned once he's the first name that
pops into the principal's head when he
hears that carrie white is going to the
prom
the novel says he's a misfit for his
huge nose and small frame
but the movie gives him his own awkward
charm
wait a second i i know just the text
before him well what do you think huh
i like it i think it's terrific look at
that no ruffles at all
the other wilson sister is mary lil
grace who is one of the nominees for
prom queen although her date doesn't
seem to have a counterpart in the book
as far as i can tell
when billy and chris are in the car
together he momentarily calls her chucky
what are you scared a nickname he uses a
couple of times to get under her skin
in the novel following the prom scene
there's one more event that takes place
sue snell is one of the only survivors
after losing her boyfriend and most of
her classmates we see her come up to the
destroyed remains of the house the
softer bloom effect in the camera is
very similar to the scene where tommy
pulls up to carrie's house to ask her to
the prom again it's very dreamlike but
this dream of sues will soon become a
nightmare
sue brings her a bouquet of flowers as
beautiful woodwind music plays but wait
these are red flowers the color of the
devil something is not right here the
cars in the background are driving
backwards
one of which may be the very same car
that billy and chris use to try to run
over carrie
the religious symbols come back for one
final appearance the for sale sign is in
the shape of a cross with vandalism
reading carrie white burns in hell
pointing down to the rubble
the last remains of the house when sue
steps onto this rubble
something changes she has entered hell
the scene becomes even more unnerving to
the subconscious as the sky turns from
blue
to black before the final horror takes
[Music]
place
and if you are a fan of horror or fan of
stephen king then you're gonna want to
subscribe to this channel because i've
got new horrors
every week including more carry coming
so make sure you ring that death bell
for notifications head to privacy.com
cz's world to get your free five dollars
and i
will see you in the next one assuming we
both survive